كم مره وقعت بالحب او وقعت في الحب لكنك
تعرضت في هذه العلاقه
للرفض لتبدا في مواجهات قلبك المكسور
ليس القلب وحده من يتاثر بالوقوع خارج
الحب بل يمتد الالم الى الدماغ بحسب دراسه
امريكيه جديده عالمه الانثروبولوجيا
البيولوجيه الدكتوره هيلين في الشارع بحثت
مع فريقها ما يحدث في ادمغتنا عندما يتم
رفض مابي بعلاقه حب واي المناطق التي تنشط
وتبقينا في دائره الذكريات
لدى لميس مشاهدينا المزيد عن القلب
المكسور والدماغ
سلامه قلوب الناس
رفض ما في احلى من الحب
الباحثه هل انفشر درست اشخاصا رفضوا حديثا
بعلاقه رفضوا حديثا بعلاقه حب ووجدت عده
اشياء تحدث في ادمغه الجميع اولها ان
منطقه الدماغ المرتبطه بمشاعر الحب
الرومانسي تصبح نشطه اذ يمكن ان تتوقف عن
حب شخص لانه هجره بل على العكس يمكن ان
تحبه اكثر كذلك المنطقه المرتبطه بمشاعر
التعلق العميق بناء تنشط ايضا فما زال
شعور التعلق بالشخص لديك مستمرا النشاط
يمتد المنطقه المرتبطه بالالم الجسدي في
الدماغ عندما يتم رفضك في علاقه حب كما ان
هناك ثلاث مناطق دماغيه تنشط وترتبط
بالرغبه والادمان كادمان الطعام مثلا
وللتخلص من هذه المعاناه والتخفيف
بالمشاعر الاسى وجدت الباحثه ان الامر
يتعلق بفتره ما بعد الرفض فمع مرور الوقت
نرى نشاطا اقل في مناطق الدماغ المرتبطه
بالتعلق اي ان الوقت كفيل بالنسيان سالنا
الناس في الاردن كيف تتجاوز علاقه عاطفيه
فاشله نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
هلا ممكن يعني
بتتجاوزيها بالشغل يعني
تلهي حالك بالشغل اكثر وممكن الواحد يتعلم
من غلطه وفي مثل بحكي لك الشاطر بتعلم من
الغلط اول اشي بدي احاول اركز على حالي
اتعلم من هاي عشان المستقبل
اركز على عيلتي على انجازاتي على شغلي
احاول احسن من حالي واتعلم عشان
العلاقات الجاي تكون اخدت خبره بهذا
الموضوع بتعرف على ناس جديده بكون
علاقات اجتماعيه كثيره يعني فبحس هذا
الشيء ممكن شوي شوي يطلعني يعني دايما
بحكي لك اكبر نجاح للانسان نفسه نجاح نفسه
فانا اذا نجحت بنفسي فاكيد بدي اتخطى اي
اشي يعني ممكن ياثر علي بعدين كل حاجه انا
تخليت عنها عشانه هالغيها
خلاص يعني فما في تنازل فيها بصراحه وخلص
وبرميها من ورا ظهري ما برجع ان انا ابكي
عليها ولا اي حاجه خلاص دي علاقه يعتبر
فاشلت خلاص وما بكررها تاني
للمزيد ينضم الينا المحلل النفسي
والاستشاري في تطوير وتدريب الذات
والمهارات الدكتور نادر ياغي اهلا بك
دكتور اهلا صباح السعاده صباح هل ينطبق ما
يفعل ذاك المطرب حينما يقول حلف عمري
اما اشوف صوره ملامح فيها من رسمك ولا
افتح كتاب يحمل معاني اسمك هل يكفي ذلك
هذه اول مره اسمع انا انا بعطيك اغاني
رومانسيه بعدين يشتغل
طبعا احنا بنتورط اكثر في العلاقه
العاطفيه وفي الحب دائما كل ما بنقول اني
انا علاقه بيني وبين هذا الشخص ودخلته في
حياتي بشكل غير طبيعي في المستقبل في
الزواج في اني انا حطيته في كل حاجه يعني
حتى في الشغل بتلاقي في ذكريات ما بيني
وبين هذا الرجل او هذه المراه هي بنت
حياتها كليتها في المستقبل انه حتى يكون
بدها تخلف ولد تسميه كذا وبدنا نعمله نعمل
اللي هي
الاحلام الورديه احنا مين اللي بيعانوا
اكثر في موضوع العواطف وبتنكسار القلب
اللي بحط امال كبيره جدا على الطرف الاخر
وبيشاركوا في كل مشاريع حياته المستقبليه
[موسيقى]
لازم امسحها انا ليش محتفظ فيها حمسح كليه
الموجود كل التسجيلات كل شيء في عندي ذكرى
الماج هذا جبته معي هي اللي جابت لي اياه
كلها هذه الاشياء منشط زيد للذاكره تبعت
العلاقه اللي بيني وبين هذا الشخص شوف
حجيب لك حاجه عشان في موضوع النسيان في
نظريه مهمه جدا انا لما باجي بقول لك او
بقول لكم انتم الاتنين الان مع ويسكو
تفكروا لا تفكر في صوره حصان يجري في
الصحراء هتفكر
يطلع ابيض هو هذا كل ما انا اقعد اقول
لنفسي انا اليوم لازم الصبح انسى عفاف اول
ما اقول عفاف عقل اللواحي طلع لي عفاف من
كل الذكريات الموجوده
على الصعيد دكتور الجسدي يقال بانه
متلازمه القلب المكسور مسؤوله عن وفاه بعض
الناس نتيجه لانتهاء علاقه لموت الشريك هل
في شيء على الصعيد الجسدي بنقدر نمنعه
لحتى نحمي اجسادنا وادمغتنا من الموت
الحقيقي عندما تموت العلاقه باي شكل بدنا
تدريب بدنا تدريب دائما نطلع دائما احنا
بنقول لما بكون في علاقه زي هادي دائما في
عنا حاجه احنا بنسميه اللي هي الموجود في
العقل نوع من انواع الادمان اللي هو
بيوديك على الادمان زي تبع الشوكولاته
والاشياء هذه لما بنخرج من هذه العلاقه
عشان ما يصير القلب المكسور عنا نوعين من
المشاكل اللي بتصير مباشره
انا جسديا بحاول اروح على العلاقه اخرى
جديده عشان انظف نفسي من العراق القديمه
او بمعنى اصح بقولوها بدك تنسى حب انسى
بحب جديد حب قديم تنساه هذه كارثه انا من
غير مؤهل الان لهذا الشيء انا لسه طالع من
فتره نقاهه او زكام فما بينفع جسمي ما
حيتحمل لان انا ممكن اقع في مشكله عاطفيه
العن من الاولانيه وهذه تحدث التانيه اللي
احنا بنقول عليها بدنا هدوء شوي ننزوي
شويه كل الاشياء اللي انا شايف بتربطني
هذه النقطه مهمه جدا تربطني بهذا الشخص
بدي ابعتها لان هي بتنشط الذاكره تبعتي
بتخلي دائما قلبي محروق والعلم فيها مراحل
كثيره جدا وكلها وانا منهم مريت كلها
بعلاقات عاطفيه اول فتره حنلاقي طعم الاكل
طعمه مر وهذا حقيقه طيب انا احنا خلص
وقتنا بس خليني اسال بانه البعض يقول اذا
غيرت جزء من الصوره تتغير الصوره يعني انا
انا ممكن هذه الذكريات تبقى معي ولكن انظر
لها من زاويه اخرى نفس موضوع ان انا رايح
على برشلونه وكان لازم تروح معي عفاف اقدر
اعالجها اقدر اعالجها واخذ واحده ثانيه
اسمها خلود او اميره خاصه القصه دكتور انت
راح تورطنا اليوم ههه
على برشلونه شكرا شكرا لعفاف وشكرا لخلود
وشكرا للمحلل النفسي والاستشاري في
التدريب وتطوير الذات والمهارات دكتور
يعني
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات